A hugely significant thing,
but I also think about it because of podcasts,
because podcasts are in a similar way that just no one saw it coming and the
people that are involved in it are like,
what the fuck are we doing?
Like me,
I'm like,
what am I doing?
Like what is this like for me?
It's like,
Ooh boy,
I get to talk to guys like Ben Greenfield and,
and Jonathan Haidt and all that,
all these different people and the learned some stuff.
And I've have clearly learned way more from doing this podcast than I ever would
have learned without it.
No doubt about it,
unquestionably.
But I didn't,
I didn't fucking plan this.
So now all of a sudden there's this a signal that I'm sending out to millions
and millions of people and then people like,
well,
you have a responsibility.
I'm like,
oh great.
Well I didn't want that.
I didn't want to responsibility to what,
what I distributed.
I just want it to be able to have a freak show.
Just talk to people like whatever.
You know,
like there's certain people that will have on whether it's Alex Jones or anyone
that's controversial where people would get fucking mad,
why are you giving this person a platform?
I go,
okay,
hmm.
I didn't think about it that way and I don't think that's what I'm doing.
I think I'm talking to people and you can listen.
Yeah,
but it's giving that person a platform because they're saying,
well no,
they'll tone down there like Milo Yiannopoulos.
That was one of the arguments people gave me.
Like he toned down his platform when he was on your show so you could get more
people to pay attention to him.
Like okay.
But he also talked about he,
he,
that was one of the reasons why he was exposed was my show because he talked
about that it's okay to have sex with underage boys if they're gay because
there's like a mentor relationship between the older gay man,
the young and people like what the fuck are you talking about?
And that was a big part of why he's kind of been removed from the public
conversation.
There was,
there was one of the thing and then there's the discussion like,
well what does that,
what is removing someone from the public conversation if someone is very popular
and they have all these people that like to listen to them,
like what is the responsibility of these platforms,
whether it's youtube or Twitter or,
or anyone.
Like what is their responsibility and to decide whether or not someone should or
shouldn't be able to speak.
And this is a thing that I've been struggling with and I've been,
I bounced around inside my own head and I see that you guys struggle with it and
pretty much everyone does.
Youtube does and it's um,
it,
it is a hugely significant discussion that is left to a very relatively small
amount of people.
And this is why this discussion of what is social media,
is it something that everybody has a right to or is it something that should be
restricted to only people that are willing to behave and carry themselves in a
certain way?
I believe it's something that everyone has a right to,
everyone has a right to,
but you still banned people.
Like,
say,
like,
like Alex Jones,
you guys were the last guys to keep Alex Jones on the platform.
You were the last ones.
Yeah.
And I believe you hung in there until he started harassing you personally,
right?
No,
no.
He,
he did not do your house.
He begged.
He,
uh,
you know,
he,
he did very different things on our platform versus the others.
So we saw this domino effect over a weekend of one platform,
uh,
banning him.
And then another,
another,
another very,
very quick succession.
And,
you know,
people I think would have assumed that we would just have followed suit,
but he didn't violate our terms of service.
Right.
And afterwards he did.
And we have,
you know,
we have a,
we have a policy and if,
if,
uh,
you know,
the,
there was a violation,
we take a enforcement actions.
One might be asking,
uh,
the account holder to delete the tweet.
Another might be,
um,
a temporary suspension.
Another might be a permanent suspension.
So,
well,
you saying let's a use in terms of like him saying that Sandy Hook was fake.
He did not say that on the platform.
He did not say that on Twitter.
He only said that on his show.
I Dunno.
I Dunno all the mediums he set it in.
What did he do?
What we're looking at is the,
is the,
is a conduct and what he did on our platforms.
So what did he do on your platform that was like,
that you all were in agreement that this is enough?
Uh,
I'm not,
I'm not sure what the,
what the actual like,
you know,
violations were.
Um,
but we have a,
we have a set number of,
of actions and if they keep getting,
if,
if an account keeps a violin in terms of service,
ultimately it leads to permanent suspension.
And when all the other platforms are taking him off,
we didn't find those.
We didn't,
we didn't find those violations and they weren't reported.
But again,
it goes back to a lot of our model people weren't reporting,
uh,
a lot of the tweets that may have been in violation on our service.
Um,
and we don't act on them.
Right.
Um,
like a good
instances.
What's going on with Patrion?
I'm sure you're aware of the Sargon of a cod thing.
He did a podcast a long time ago,
uh,
I believe six months or so ago where he used the n word and the way he used it
as a actually against white nationalists.
Um,
and he also said a bunch of other stuff and they decided,
patrion decided that what he said on a podcast was enough for them to remove him
from the platform even though he didn't do anything on their platform.
That was agregious.
And also they had previously stated that they were all in the judging things
that occurred on their platform.
There's been a giant blow back because of that because people are saying,
well now you're,
you're essentially policing and not based on his actions,
just on concepts and the communication that he was using,
the way he was talking a year.
You are eliminating him from being able to
make a living and that you're doing this because he does not fit into your
political paradigm the way you want to view the world.
He have used the world differently.
This is an opportunity for you to eliminate someone who you disagree with.
Yeah,
I mean,
I don't know the nuances of their policy about like we,
we have to pay attention to folks who are using Twitter to shut down the voices
of others.
Right?
That's where it gets weaponized.
And we also have to pay attention to where people are using it that put other
folks in physical danger.
And that is where we need to be most severe.
But otherwise,
everyone has a right to these technologies.
And I think they also have a right to make sure that they have a very simple and
open read of the rules.
And,
and we're not in a great state.
There are rules in our enforcement can be extremely confusing to people.